>>> THREE GROUPS HAD THIS
LETTER THAT WAS ASKED TO BE
ANONYMOUS.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND HER
STAFF.
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM CALIFORNIA
AND HER STAFF.
AND THE LAWYERS.
SOMEBODY BETRAYED HER TRUST.
IF YOU CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHY,
YOU SHOULDN'T DRIVING.
>> Tucker: CHRSTINE BLASEY
FORD HAD WANTED TO REMAIN
ANONYMOUS.
SHE DIDN'T WANT TO TESTIFY
YESTERDAY AND DIDN'T WANT
ANYONE TO KNOW HER NAME.
SHE ONLY WENT PUBLIC WITH THE
ALLEGATIONS AFTER SOMEBODY
LEAKED THEM TO THE PRESS.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
ONLY A FEW PEOPLE KNEW ABOUT
THE LETTER THAT SHE HAD
WRITTEN TO CONGRESSMAN AND
THAT IT MADE ITS WAY TO
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN'S
OFFICE.
FROM ONE OF THE OFFICES HER
IDENTITY MADE IT TO REPORTERS.
WHO DID THAT?
AND WHY AREN'T DEMOCRATS
INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT THE
IDENTITY OF THE PERSON WHO DID
THAT?
SINCE SUPPOSEDLY THEY CARE SO
DEEPLY ABOUT CHRISTINE FORD.
McCARTHY WAS ANS SAYTANT
U.S. ATTORNEY, AND JUDGE WAS A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
WASHINGTON AND THEY JOIN US.
WHY WOULDN'T BE SO HARD TO
FIND OUT HOW THE INFORMATION
GOT FROM ONE OF TWO
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICES TO THE
"WASHINGTON POST"?
>> TUCKER, IF WE ASSUME IT HAD
TO BE ONE OF THE TWO OFFICES
THEN IT SHOULD BE A SMALL
WORLD OF PEOPLE.
I THINK THE PROBLEM WE HAVE,
FACTUALLY, IS THAT THE FIRST
PRESS OUTLET WHO GOT IT, THE
INTERCEPT NOW SAYS THAT
FEINSTEIN, SENATOR FEINSTEIN
WAS NOT THE SOURCE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
OTHER CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSPERSON COULD NOT BE
THE SOURCE OR IT COULD HAVE
COME FROM THE LAWYERS OR WHAT
HAPPENS AN ACQUAINTANCE OR
FRIEND OF DR. FORD.
BUT WHILE IT IS A SMALL AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
CIRCLE OF THE POSSIBLE LEAKER,
AND IF YOU MADE AN AGGRESSIVE
INVESTIGATION YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO GET SOME LEADS
QUICKLY.
CERTAINLY, IF KAVANAUGH CAN BE
INVESTIGATED SEVEN TIMES YOU
THINK IT MIGHT BE WORTH A ONCE
OVER.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD THINK
THAT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
>> Tucker: IF YOU CARED
ABOUT CHRISTINE FORD WOULDN'T
YOU CARE WHO BETRAYED HER AND
OVERTURNED HER LIFE?
>> OF COURSE YOU WOULD.
BUT THIS IS NOT WHAT IT IS
ABOUT FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE ETHICS
OR MORALITY OR RIGHTNESS.
THIS IS ABOUT POWER.
THE DEMOCRATS LEAKED IT, THE
LAWYERS LEAKED IT, MAYBE SHE
LEAKED IT OR SOMEONE IN HER
FAMILY LEAKED.
WE KNOW THE REPUBLICANS DIDN'T
LEAK IT BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE LETTER.
SOMEONE WANTED TO USE HER AND
MAKE PARROT OF A PROCESS TO
FLAY AWAY AT JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
THIS IS PART OF THE DISGUSTING
DISPLAY THAT THE DEMOCRATS
CREATED.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT
LOOK LIKE SOMETHING THAT IS
SERIOUS.
IN FACT, IT'S AWFUL.
IT IS DEMEANING THE COUNTRY
AND DEMEANING THE SENATE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT AFFECT IT IS
HAVING ON DR. FORD OR WHATEVER
HER NAME IS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THIS
IS AN ATTEMPT TO DESTROY A
GOOD MAN AND HIS FAMILY.
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SUCCEEDING.
THEY GOT THEIR DELAY ON THE
VOTE ON THE STATE FLOOR.
THEY MAY ULTIMATELY WIN.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THIS AND WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF ALL OF THIS?
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>> THAT IT IS PHENOMENAL THAT
THE DEMOCRATS COULD NOT MORE
CLEARLY SIGNAL THAT WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT IS THE DELAY,
DELAY, DELAY.
NO MATTER WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
WHETHER IT'S THE VICTIMS OR
THE SURVIVORS OR SOMEBODY
PRIVACY OR THE NEED FOR AN
F.B.I. INVESTIGATION.
IT'S ALL ABOUT DELAY.
AND YET THE REPUBLICANS SEEM
TO THINK IF WE JUST GIVE THEM
A LITTLE BIT MORE DELAY WE CAN
BRING THIS THING TO CLOSURE.
FOR THE LIFE OF ME I CAN'T
WRAP MY BRAIN AROUND THAT.
>> Tucker: I CAN'T EITHER.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANYTHING THIS
CYNICAL?
YOU HAVE BEEN HERE A LONG
TIME.
>> NO.
>> I CAME HERE IN 1967.
51 YEARS AGO.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
TO WATCH SENATOR COON DO AN
UMPTIOUS DESCRIPTION HOW
WONDERFUL IT WAS TO WORK WITH
SENATOR FLAKE AND ALL WE WANT
IS A LITTLE MORE TIME.
THE GOOFY, GISTING PERFORMANCE
BY THE DEMOCRATS.
THE SENATE USED TO BE A
BEAUTIFUL PLACE.
NOW IT'S A VERY, VERY UGLY
PLACE AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE BEING HARMED BY THIS.
THIS IS AWFUL.
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE ONE WIT.
THEY JUST CARE ABOUT POWER.
>> Tucker: TRUE.